[Applaudissements]
avec le décès du metteur en scène André
Brassard le Québec perd un pionnier et
Michel Tremblay perd son grand complice
cette nuit évidemment j'ai peu dormi la
nuit après son décès et c'est
effectivement
je me suis joué le matin le film de nos
40 ans je pense qu'il faut faire un
choix André Brassard avait à peine 22
ans lorsqu'en 1968 il signe la mise en
scène de la pièce Les Belles sorts de
Michel Tremblay la complicité du tandem
brassard Tremblay a eu l'effet d'une
véritable petite révolution dans le
théâtre québécois je pense qu'on avait
tous les deux
une parenté dans le fait de retourner
les drames à quelque chose de comique
avec
sa compréhension des textes de jeunesse
André Brassard était audacieux passionné
et parfois sans compromis dans les
années 70 Lauren Pintal faisait partie
de son cercle rapproché finalement j'ai
découvert un
adolescent qui n'avait jamais vieilli
qui découvre qui lui avait toujours
cette espèce de d'éblouissement devant
les acteurs devant la pièce à monter et
quelqu'un aussi qui avait une faille
parce qu'on le sait qu'il y avait une
faille André c'était quelqu'un de
douloureux ne verrez rien de tout cela
entre deux ovation en coulisses la vie
d'André Brassard a été ponctuée par la
consommation de drogues et d'épisodes de
dépression en 1975 il a été condamné
pour grossière indécence après qu'on ne
retrouvait chez lui des photos de jeune
homme
âgés de 14 à 20 ans il en avait parlé à
son biographe Guillaume Corbeil
j'aimerais rappeler aussi
souvent les gens qui font des choses
comme ça c'est des gens qui
souffrentissent comme je disais André
Brassard et c'est quelqu'un qui a pas il
y a pas eu d'amour lui c'est quelqu'un
que sa mère avait pas le droit de le
coller de en public parce que c'est
parce que à l'époque André comprenne que
c'était sa mère et donc c'est quelqu'un
qui a souffert toute sa vie d'un grand
manque d'amour André Brassard a
tranquillement quitté la scène après un
accident vasculaire cérébral survenu en
1999 lentement mais sûrement le rideau
est tombé il y a tellement peu de soin
de lui à partir du moment où il y a eu
son premier AVC en 99 c'est ce qui nous
a séparés d'ailleurs c'est c'est en fait
c'est mon exaspération devant le fait
que je trouvais qu'il était pas assez
que fait qu'on a eu un problème qu'on a
eu un problème ensemble que ce soit au
théâtre ou au cinéma André Brassard nous
a fait rire et pleurer lui qui a
toujours voulu être aimé aura réussi à
nous transmettre son amour du théâtre
d'interrompre cette chaleur ici lui il
fait depuis